[Musik]
dws gerissen der mantel zeigt machen wir
nochmal jetzt nochmal jetzt nochmal
alter noch mal
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja da ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut heute ein super
interessantes thema haben wir uns
überlegt wir haben ja vor ungefähr drei
vier wochen zusammen
geschockt du hast ja ganz schnell weißt
du noch oder ganz fix ganz viele sachen
ausgesuchte bei bcg seite genau
berlin ja so was so gut klingen
screenshot dass er richtig im trend
das hört sich doch gut aus da jetzt
einfach rein du kannst reinhauen
ja wenn sie sich alle sachen hässlich
finden ich könnte dir einen tipp geben
mache einfach dann lächeln im neuen tab
oder im shop gesucht waren auch schon
ein paar von dem geschäftsbereich muss
nicht zu mir und vernünftig ja es sind
halt standard shirts weiter bei rover
war dass das ist nämlich so eine
ähnliche seite wie wish und einige
andere blödsinn und eine sache zum
beispiel diese wir haben also
unzerstörbares nica bestellt kann sich
daran noch das habe ich schon getestet
aber du hast ja auch praktisch ein
ganzes outfit zusammengestellt wir haben
da glaube ich ich kann ja mal kurs
erstmal die sachen holen oder also ich
muss sagen genau weiß ich jetzt auch
nicht was dabei aber wir haben auf jeden
fall 123
45 sachen kann sich weiß macht was das
war also eine jeans jacken hosen schuhe
ein t shirt kann marie den das mal kurz
noch einmal durch damit wir es ungefähr
wissen oder warum ist einfach so
anschauen also einfach so ich will nur
einmal ganz kurz durchschauen an sich
ist aber ein ganzes outfit und wir
schauen dann aber gleich wie du in der
outfit aussiehst in diesem outfit passt
es zu großer nähe in dem outfit was
ungefähr profiturnier war es so
insgesamt 30 euro 40 euro mit versandt
teilt also die sachen an sich sind
natürlich noch günstiger willst du
selber die sachen hausbau oder wie
machen wir das kann mal jemand an
ich bin jetzt aber auch nicht sicher ob
das alles auch das alles dazugehört weil
ich habe in köln suchen wir sagten hier
das ist manager hat übrigens morgen
geburtstag das ist übrigens ein
geburtstagsgeschenk nicht es bestehe ja
hast du alter das echt billig nicht
schlimm
durch schlechte politiker selten gesehen
ok also das ist teil nummer eins wollte
ich mal ganz kurz nach oben und schaut
einmal die sachen durch damit ich den
die einmal zeigen kann
ich habe jetzt nur noch alle sachen
gefunden kommen ein bisschen drüber dann
haben die leute hier platzen sehen und
zwar stadler hiermit diese hose haben
wir die bestellt weiß man welche farbe
okay werden wir gleich sehen aber man
muss schon sagen ist eigentlich im sinne
hat neun euro 53 gekostet als nächstes
genau diese modi der liegt da ja schon
kann der sieht auf den fotos echt gut
aus
und dann kriegt man sonst also was hat
er gekostet sieben euro ja gut so viel
kann man da und erwarten dann haben wir
genau diese hose weil sie noch immer mit
geld und mithelfen würde glaube ich
bestellt
also das ist glaube ich mein favorit von
von allen sachen 18 euro kostet
den wenig bestellen nehme ich auch nicht
weiter überhaupt dabei doch klar ist für
den bestellten schwarz und guck mal hier
26 eur 25 und zu guter letzt haben wir
hier noch genau die schuhe
das sind doch keine schuhe oder was
sagst du dazu
wir schärfen ok also das waren alle
sachen dann können wir jetzt weiter aus
konnten wir hier ist schon wieder
und was kann man getragen
richtig schwierig doch ganz normal oder
ja schön sommerlich man wie das zusammen
fit ist mit dem preis nicht engagiert zu
groß die ist nicht so groß eine ziemlich
cool so als nächstes wir keine ahnung
das liegt auf jeden fall ein bisschen
hochwertiger oben im wald verschlüsselt
und ist jetzt dass der mantel der sie
auf dem foto anders
also wenn man irgendwas zum produkt
nicht versteht kann man es ganz einfach
wie man hier nachlesen mit ein paar
daten und fakten dazu ganz wichtig und
aber ist hier doch größe m steht da
drauf
ok den kann man dann natürlich wenn es
jetzt kalt wird draußen kannst du den
richtig gut dazu anziehen und das findet
natürlich auch mit der türkei sehr gut
machen wir weiter
guck mal noch deutsche börse
das war die erste was ist der auslöser
dieser anders aus dem stoff
irgendwie denke ich manchmal die tun da
irgendwas in der post das halbwegs so
ähnlich aussieht und der kunde gibt sich
damit zufrieden weiß wenn nur euro
kostet oder so ist halt in den meisten
fällen noch welche hinzu was die oder
die gelbe egal war okay dann ist meister
und die kriegt man schenke ich dir jetzt
was auch für das kannst du auch machen
sneaker unboxing
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen ich finde die schule
eigentlich gar nicht mal schlecht welche
schule ist haben wir die noch mal
verstärkt 42 oder so würde die jetzt
auch privat tragen so was sicher okay
dann ist willst du jetzt mal auf die
kleine kamera und dann kannst du das ja
mal anziehen und dann schauen wir wie es
aussieht okay also die show auf jeden
fall haben wir schon mal dann die hose
mit der gelb aktie
dann sind wohl hier oder und was fehlt
noch der mantel darüber und das t shirt
kannst ja das ist okay leute da wird es
gleich mehr denn je das tier kurz und
fuhr und dann kommst du gleich einfach
wieder wenn du das ganze outfit an hass
oder ok und ohne mantel erstmal noch ja
ok bis gleich und was machst du gerade
in der zwischenzeit mario kart clubs um
aliens ausschnitt wird wird cool so ja
aber was würdest du sagen zu groben
einschätzung weil das immer das beste
wenn alle hier so richtig kommunikativ
sind um in ihrem video zu machen da
freue ich mich immer richtig toben am
besten drehe ich einfach jedes video
alleine ok und bitte so ach so okay
jetzt heißt es erstmal nur die hose an
dass die stadt gehört ja nicht dazu hier
titus jetzt warte man darf ich mal den
mantel hat hier ein am besten uns hier
nicht besser ok also jetzt siehst du
noch den who die am besten darüber in
der guten qualität was ist mit dem ist
er zu groß nein so bleiben
gut größerem ist das also an sich klar
das passt jetzt hier nicht so mit dem
weißen und dem und jetzt am besten hier
kurz die schuhe dazu zeigt mal zeigen
was die schuhe können
das sieht gut aus und jetzt in anderen
noch doch kommen muss her sonst sehe ich
das an wenn das keine anziehen will
ok ja an sich ganz gut und jetzt kommt
noch als kleines finale hier der mantel
so geil alter heftig heftiges outfit
also sag nochmal hier wenn ich jetzt wie
viel ist in dein auto bird sagte hirsch
uhr 17 euro wo sie 5 wo die zehn mantel
20 ich bin blind an den endpreis ein auf
jeden fall ein geiles auto feiere ich so
jetzt gehen wir mal raus und machen noch
kurz diesem pass lohmar aufnahmen okay
wer ist gerissen
der mantel noch mal noch mal war
jetzt warte man jetzt noch mal alter
noch mal bereist und ja das hört sich
nicht so an ist aber noch heile ja ja
also das spiegelt sich die qualität
wieder
aber ich würde sagen so wenn ich dich
jetzt damit sehen würde
[Musik]
ja geil ist auch für also würde ich auch
hätte ich mir auch in meiner größe
geholt wenn das ist zu geben würde ja
heute so vielen dank erstmal du kannst
ja mal kurz sagen müsse es auch privat
zu tragen
sicher ist sein team und auch so dass
schinken und die hose eventuell die
schuhe also ich finde die schule sei
eigentlich das highlight vom weißen
outfit leute wenn euch die schule
gefallen gibt man noch nach oben oder
schreibt in die kommentare und
turnschuhe
ansonsten habe jetzt gedanken machen
jetzt mal ein geiles forderung den
posten weil die open instagram account
ist wenn ich hier ein und dann können
die leute dass alle live und schreiben
ist das ein geiles auto oder nein
naja ich bin euch trotzdem hier mehr
lienz installation einmal vorbeischauen
und wir sehen unseren morgen um die 49
19 uhr genau wird es ein neues video und
das war's aber nur den kanal glocke
aktivieren
oder hat noch irgendjemand was zu sagen